There are several syntactical tricks
available to make closure expressions
super concise.
In fact, this is one of the coolest
aspects of closure expressions in Swift
and at times,
one of the most confounding.
I want to walk you through some of these
tricks using the filter method from
the array class.
The filter method is called by
an instance of the array class.
As an argument,
It takes in a condition and
returns an array that's been
filtered based on that condition.
The condition is passed in as a closure.
Here i have an array of exam grades.
I'm going to filter this array for
all the grades above 70.
We'll call those grades, passing grades.
So I call the filter method with
the object, exam grades and
I pass in a closure representing
the filter condition.
The closure takes in a grade and it and
returns a bull representing
whether the condition is true.
At this point, this looks a lot
like the syntax we saw for sorted.
Here's the first trick.
The compiler can infer
a closure expression types
based on what parameter type
a given function expects.
In this case, the compiler can infer
that the closure expression for filter
will take in a parameter that matches
the type of the array being filtered.
And the compiler can also infer that
this closure will return a bull.
That means we can leave out
the words int and bull and
still get the same result.
Here in the sidebar you can see
what the result is if we filter for
failing grades.
On to the next trick.
If a closure is a single
expression like this one.
It can be inferred that the result of
that expression should be returned.
So we can remove the word return,
again in the sidebar,
you can see that our filter still works.
And now for the trick that's been known
to make some code readers head spin.
Shorthand argument names.
Swift provides default argument
names for closure expressions.
So instead of specifying
a first argument,
the first argument is known as $0.
The second argument is known as $1 and
so on.
So here, for example,
the compiler can infer that this closure
expression takes one argument and
that its type, int, matches the type
of the elements in the array.
So we don't have to give it a name,
grade.
We just use the default name for
the first argument, $0.
And since we're not giving
grade a name anymore
we can omit the word grade
along with the word in.
Let's see all those short
cuts again one more time.
We'll go back to the alphabetical
soup example from your quiz.
The closure expression parameter and
return types can be inferred.
So we can take out String,
String and Bool.
Since this is a single
expression closure.
It can be inferred that it returns
the result of that single expression.
So we can also leave out return.
We can use the shorthand argument
names for soup one and soup two.
And we're left with a statement
that truly is amazingly concise.